مرحبًا بك في البرنامج من واشنطن ،
اسمحوا لي أولاً أن أسألك كيف
كانت السنوات الأربع الماضية والآن نرى
المزيد والمزيد من أفراد أسرتك الذين
هم في الخارج مثلك والدك
وأخوك ونفسك يصعدون من
الضغط العام على المملكة العربية السعودية.  الحكومة
حسنًا ، لقد كنا أه نعيش
كابوسًا حقيقيًا خلال السنوات الأربع الماضية أه
كان الأمر فظيعًا
أخبرني كيف حدث
ما هو
الكابوس الافتقار إلى الأمن والأمان تخيل
نفسك لقد تم استهداف
والدك بفرق رئيسية أه  أشقائك يُسجنون
ويُتهمون بأشياء لم
يفعلوها قط زوجي أه
سُجن زوجك وخطف ثم
عُذب ،
أخشى على أطفالي أن
أستيقظ كل صباح لمجرد التحقق
من صحة الجميع وما هي الأخبار السيئة الجديدة
قال ،
دعني أطلب منك فقط وصف
كيف ومتى تم أخذ زوجك
وكيف انتهى به المطاف في السجن وماذا
كان يحدث له في السنوات
العديدة الماضية ماذا كان  في
ظل الظروف التي حدث فيها ذلك ،
كنا نعيش في دبي والمطار
الذي مُنع من السفر عندما
كنا نزور الأصدقاء في تلك اللحظة ، كان علينا
أن نفصل ، لقد
اصطحبت أطفالي لإيوائهم لأنني
ترددت في البقاء معه أم
لا  بعد شهر ، تم
اختطافه وكان مخفيًا قسريًا لمدة
شهرين
بعد ذلك عندما خرج من فندق ريتز
كارلتون ،
علمنا أنه كان
رئيسًا لعدة سجون
تعرض للتعذيب الوحشي ، رأيت العلامات على
جسده أخبرني كثيرًا  من
الأشياء التي لا يمكنك تخيلها
إذا ذكرت فندق ريتز كارلتون والذي
اشتهر أنه كان المكان الذي تم فيه اعتقال الكثير
من المعارضين
منذ عدة سنوات حيث
تم اتهامهم بتكديس ثروات ضخمة بشكل غير صحيح
وغير عادل
أراد ولي العهد أن تُعاد تلك الثروة
إلى الأمة هو أن
ما تتحدث عنه هو أن فندق
ريتز كارلتون الذي تتحدث عنه وهذا هو
السبب في أن زوجك كان بروج.  ht في
هذا بالضبط فندق ريتز كارلتون حيث
كان زوجي وقد أُجبر تحت
التعذيب على التوقيع على جميع أصوله
وثروته من أجل حريته ولكن
هذا ليس السبب الرئيسي الذي نعرف جميعًا
أن السبب الرئيسي هو أه استهداف والدي
لأنه  تم أخذه مرة أخرى
في أغسطس / آب عام 2020 ، وهو في
حالة اختفاء قسري ، لا أعرف
مكانه ، لا أعرف كيف هو.
أنا
متأكد تمامًا من أن هذا هو السبب في أنه
تم نقله إلى الحكومة السعودية
كما نقرأ ، وسأعيد قراءته الآن لأنك تقول
إن سارة وعمر هما
إخوتك وسنتحدث عنهما في
ثانية
.  حاولت بغسل
الأموال والتآمر للهروب من
المملكة بشكل غير قانوني وتم وضع زوجك رسميًا
للتوقيع على تسوية لتسليم
أصوله في محاولة لمكافحة الفساد
كنت قد تحدثت عن ذلك نوعًا ما ولكن
هذا هو السبب في أنهم يقولون المملكة إن
أقاربك  تم تقريب ش  ع
بسبب الجرائم المزعومة التي ارتكبوها
وهذا ليس صحيحًا
هذه كذبة إنهم أبرياء
جميعهم أبرياء زوجي
أختي وأخي وأبي هم فقط أه
إنه ثأر شخصي من mbs
ضد والدي وهو يشمل
العائلة  الأعضاء فيه ،
فهل يمكنك أن تشرحي لي لماذا
يكون لديه هذا الثأر من والدك ،
ما هو الأمر بالنسبة لوالدك ، نحن نعلم
أنه مسؤول استخبارات سابق
في المملكة ولكن ما
الذي تشعر أنه قد
جذب هذا إليه؟  نوع من الاهتمام
من المملكة جيدًا تحدث والدي
وقال إنه يخشى ما يعرفه ما
يعرفه والدي أنه سيؤثر عليه ويكون
بعيدًا عنها على العرش كما لو
كان عائقًا أمامه
بالنسبة لـ mbs
نعم
و  ولماذا أعني ما كان
منصب والدك ، قم فقط بملء القليل من
تلك التفاصيل للجمهور
الذي فعلك ، أعني كيف وقع في
خطأ ومتى وقع في مخالفة مع
الرجل الذي توج الآن أميرًا
وحاكمًا فعليًا  من أمتك
كان والدي يعمل
مع ولي العهد السابق ،
فقد كان مستشاره الشخصي الذي ساعده في
هجمات مكافحة الإرهاب ومنع تلك
الهجمات وإنقاذ الكثير من المواطنين السعوديين والأوروبيين الأحياء في
جميع أنحاء
العالم وعندما حدث التلسكوب مرة أخرى
في  ارتفع عام 2000 2017
أم رمي nbs لإلقاء أول
أمر له ، ثم كان منع سارة وعمر
من ركوب طائرتهما والسفر إلى
الولايات المتحدة حيث كان من المفترض أن يكملوا
دراستهم ، لذلك بدأ في استهداف
أفراد الأسرة منذ ذلك الحين
لإغراء والدي  بالعودة إلى السعودية ،
فالشخصان اللذان ذكرتهما هما
أشقائك ، وصحح أختك
وأخوك المحتجزان في المملكة العربية السعودية
كما تقول ما هو نوع دليل إثبات الحياة
على أنهما على قيد الحياة أو
أين هم.
المعلومات التي لديك عنهم ،
لا نعرف الكثير عن أنهم مسجونون في
الرياض ، يتصلون بأفراد العائلة هناك
من حين لآخر ، أحيانًا نكون
محظوظين لسماعهم من خلال مكبر الصوت ، لكن
بخلاف ذلك لا نعرف المزيد من
التفاصيل ما نعرفه هو
أنهم أبرياء ويجب أن يخرجوا هذه
ليست طريقة أه لإلقاء القبض
على الأبرياء وأفراد الأسرة
عليهم وسحب حقوقهم الإنسانية الأساسية
منهم.  الأطفال الأبرياء الذين يجب أن
يدرسوا الآن ويعيشوا حياتهم الصغيرة